I am a labor organizer,
and in 2013, I cofounded
an organization called coworker.org
that uses technology
to help people join with coworkers
and organize for improvements
in the workplace.
Now, there are two kinds
of reactions to what I do.
Actually, no, there are three.
The first is complete confusion
about what organizing is.
When my doctor asked
what I do and I told him,
he thought I meant organizing,
like, Marie Kondo-style.
(Laughter)
He was like, "Oh, that's so great,
I could use some of that around here.
I would love to clean up
our patient files."
And I had to explain to him that no, no,
it's not that kind of organizing,
it's more like if you showed up
to work tomorrow
and all the nurses in the office
had gotten together
to ask for an across-the-board raise.
(Laughter)
"Oh," he replied, and he got really quiet.
Yeah, and that's
the second kind of reaction:
the uncomfortable kind.
People usually withdraw
from the conversation
and find someone else to talk to.
Finally, there's the third reaction,
the excited one,
the, "Oh my God, yes! We need this!"
And someone always proceeds
to tell me a story.
It's always a story about a job
or a coworker or a friend
who's enduring something awful at work.
What I've noticed is that there is never
a neutral response to what I do.
You're either repelled by it,
or you're struck with
a lightning bolt of excitement.
So why does my work stir up
such strong reactions?
My hunch is that it's about conflict.
If you have power in your workplace,
maybe as a CEO
or a senior leader of some kind,
you're going to feel uncomfortable
with that power being challenged.
But if you lack power, or you know someone
who lacks it and needs it,
you might grab me by the shoulders
and shake me, you're so pumped.
But really, we can all benefit
from understanding
what conflict can offer in our workplaces.
The power imbalance
in our workplace is real,
and it's constantly changing.
Power moves between us,
depending on our roles and status.
Now, sometimes this can feel
like office politics, right?
Which is never fun.
But when we contest
for power thoughtfully
and together with our coworkers,
it can be incredibly productive.
And it's that kind of productive conflict
that I want to talk
to you all about today,
the kind that can make
some of us uncomfortable.
Business leaders should embrace
when their workers conflict
with policies and decisions,
both for what it teaches us
and for what it says about
our commitment to each other.
So what do I mean by
"productive conflict"?
Well, let me tell you a story.
In 2016, a store employee
for an outdoor retailer --
I'll call her "Alex" --
Alex approached her boss
and asked for a raise.
Now, she was told her pay
was fairly standard for her position
and that her boss didn't even have
the authority to give such a raise.
And that was supposed to be
the end of the conversation.
Unhappy with that answer,
Alex went home, and she decided
to create a campaign on coworker.org,
asking the corporate office
to give raises to store employees.
Within days, employees
from around the country
began joining Alex's effort
and sharing their own stories
about what they were earning --
11, 12 dollars an hour --
and how that wage
was impacting their lives.
Some even shared
that they had quit recently
to work for competitors who paid more.
But here's the thing: they also shared
that they didn't want to quit,
they liked their job, they believed
in the company's mission,
but for them, the pay issue
was a growing problem in their work lives.
Well, after weeks of this groundswell
of employee activism,
the company decided to raise wages
by five to 15 percent
in cities across the country.
And that's what I mean
by productive conflict:
pushing up against the things
that aren't working for us
when there exists no other path forward.
The other thing I learned
in doing this work
is that people engage
in productive conflict
when they care about their jobs
and their coworkers.
Now, that surprised me at first.
I expected the worst jobs,
the worst workplaces,
to have the most
employee activism on our site,
but the opposite is often true.
When we come together,
we can accomplish great things.
At one company,
there are more than 50 campaigns
by employees there
on issues ranging from dress code changes
to legitimate safety concerns.
And get this:
that same company has
the lowest voluntary turnover rate
of any major chain in its sector.
And it also has one of the higher
productivity rates as well.
Business leaders:
you shouldn't fear conflict,
and you shouldn't try to tamp down on it
the minute it bubbles up
in your workforce.
While it can introduce uncertainties
that can be difficult to manage,
those uncertainties are trying
to tell you something
about an underlying problem
that needs your attention.
And I think this is
especially important right now,
you know, as technology
transforms nearly everyone's job
and as the structures
that contain our work
are changing at a pace not seen
since the Industrial Revolution.
We all need to be shaping
and participating in the future of work.
We all need to be challenging
and changing the parts of our work lives
that are broken.
So I hope the next time
a coworker invites you
maybe to join a sign-on
letter to your boss,
or a group of employees asks for a meeting
to discuss their concerns
about the new health care plan,
I hope you'll consider it an opportunity
to build a better workplace,
a stronger business
and an economy that works for all of us.
Thank you.
(Applause)